i don't really follow alex jones but i
did have an you know we we we always
goof on him with our fake alex jones and
stuff he went berserk on gene simmons of
kiss for some reason what did you do
gene said something about anti-vaxxers
are evil
and then alex jones went berserk i've
got a very important message for gene
simmons you're not going to inject my
children with your [ __ ] poisons you
piece of [ __ ] and you and your [ __ ]
band are going to burn in hell before
you ever get control of this nation for
the record gene didn't even mention
alex's name he he made his comments on
this podcast talk shop live he was
discussing how vaccinations were
required for the upcoming kiss cruise
you know who that is
alex jones here we go aren't you busy
infowars.com
infowars.com
we are at war people they lied about the
frankenstein they lied about the
afghanistan baby trade don't listen to
them don't listen to them and that
stupid demon and make up that fat
bloated pervert gene simmons they want
to poison you stern they want to poison
you uh oh excuse me alex
who's a his arch enemy uh gene simmons
of kiss
hi gene how are you
howard i'm glad you brought him in it's
gene simmons
from kiss
mr long tongue mr demon scumbag hello
demon scumbag alex i don't know why
you're coming after me you're publicly
criticizing me for telling people to get
the vaccine oh i'm just telling people
to get the fat the vaccine's a damn rat
poison simmons it's a rat poison they
want to wipe out humanity you goddamn
dumbass alex you make as much sense as
rush limbaugh when he's detoxing off of
oxies
look you want to hear a real conspiracy
theory alex you're in great shape please
i'm in excellent shape everybody knows
i'm in great shape here's some fat old
man wearing makeup and high heels and
we're not going to listen to you about
health simmons do you hear me you demon
you're making fun of my appearance you
look like you snort horse tranquilizers
and [ __ ] giraffe [ __ ] that's how stupid
you are you don't snort you huff horse
tranquilizers and you don't know that
because you wear your dumb clown outfits
and you eat bad heads listen i don't
listen to you and your goddamn chicken
[ __ ] music simmons f u f u i've guys i
feel like i'm in the middle of godzilla
versus king kong the two of you guys i
don't even know what these arguments are
about uh
whoever thought that gene simmons and
alex jones would be at war with one
another it is a war isn't it alex this
is a war we are at war with this demonic
scumbag sure can we
hold on
uh oh
the alarms going off you know what that
means that must mean there are
alarmingly low prices at infowars.com
oh yes
right now through the weekend we got
half off the ultra forced dna shield 90
hour clean energy with vitamins new
tropics and paint chips half off x2
iodine toothpaste which doubles as an
ant poison squirted on an anthill
they'll die on contact
free store-wide shipping with promo code
gene simmons baloney tits at
infowars.com infowars.com
i don't think alex believes anything
he's saying i think he does everything
for financial gain i really believe that
and i wrote a book about it and it's
available right now for a limited time
go to
kissonline.com click on alex jones's
inverted penis and type in promo code
d-platformed
all right well guys uh enough of the
plug there's anything people should take
advantage of it's the mega blowout
stocking stuff for sale going on he got
25 off the liberty food buckets the
rolls-royce of powdered food and you get
the immune cleanse it's gonna wash out
the drinkable microchips that they're
putting in your water full of bleach
cling out like a whistle triple patriot
points at infowars.com
[Music]
can i just mention one thing
it's dueling plugs here what is it
it's only 24 more days until christmas
so right now for a limited time get your
kiss christmas tree your kiss rockin
eggnog recipes with animalized wrapping
paper and where do you find it you go to
kissonline.com you go to kissonline.com
because they want lights out for
humanity but you'll never get caught in
the dark with the new infowars survival
flashlight reinforced with high grade
tinfoil shines at 2 trillion lumens
infowars.com
wow even your music beds are at war guys
all right listen uh 25 more days until
kwanzaa hello black people
i know you don't know who i am my name
is keem simmons i'm in a heavy metal
band called kids
online.com infowars.com
join the fight join the war we are at
war infowars.com all right thank you
gene thank you good luck with your kiss
uh cruz and kiss kwanzaa uh thank you
very much
[Music]
bye guys